and in the ballroom of the Mayflower
Hotel in Washington another party
the dignitaries of the New Deal gather
for the traditional victory dinner that
celebrates their triumph at the presidential polls
if Franklin Roosevelt's first term began
at a time of crisis for the country his
second begins at a time of crisis for
the New Deal if his first four years
were marked by controversy and contention his
second four star for the political bombshell
that divides the nation and splits his
own party he attacks the Supreme Court
and I defy anyone to read the opinions concerning
the triple-a the railroad retirement Act the
National Recovery Act the GAVI coal Act some wage
law and tell us exactly what if anything we can
do for the industrial world this section of the
Congress with any reasonable certainty that what
we do will not be nullified as unconstitutional if
we would keep faith faith with those who had faith
in us if we would make democracy succeed I say
we must act now the president calls on Congress
to support his fight against what he terms the
horse-and-buggy decisions of the Supreme Court
he asks that the court be liberalized by adding
more and younger justices calling his program
court reformed but opponents denounced it
as court packing and Roosevelt suffers a
jolting setback when his plan is decisively
rejected the New Deal honeymoon is over
but another major New Deal measure sponsored
by Senator Robert Wagner of New York is
unexpectedly approved by the Supreme Court and
new life is given to the American labor move